da geht es um das thema energie im balco
aus europa fließen täglich hunderte
millionen euro für öl gas und kohle
anderes land ein kohle embargo ist
inzwischen beschlossen tritt aber erst
im august in kraft die eu kommission
schlägt auch ein öl embargo gegen
russland vor darüber gibt es streit in
der eu deutschland unterstützt das
vorhaben doch ungarn mauert die afg
fraktion hat zwei anträge vorgelegt zum
thema öl und energie embargo mehr
erfahren wir jetzt vom ersten redner
stephen corry für die kfd
gesagt dass jede woche ohne uhr embargo
eine gute woche ist und recht hat er und
ich sage dass jedes jahr ohne embargo
und ohne sanktion ein gutes ja ist denn
diese embargos die schädigen und meine
damen und herren und
herr minister habeck hat uns ja auch
getäuscht er hat gesagt wir würden also
von diesem 5 35 prozentigen anteil
russischen bild schon längst auf 12
prozent gesunken sein ich habe die
bundesregierung gefragt also kam
mitnichten die antwort dass das bekannt
sei und auch nicht woher also wir dann
dieses öl dann hätten beziehen sollen
und welche sorte und wie auch immer also
es wird vermutet ich mal mitnichten so
der fall sein zumindest weist die
bundesregierung darüber nichts und das
ist eine unverantwortliche politik denn
sie müsste genau wissen was jetzt hier
zu tun ist und woher das öl kommt meine
damen und herren aber man sieht daran
man sieht daran dass hier mehr
durchhalteparolen geschwungen werden und
mehr durchhalte propaganda gemacht wird
als das reale politik hier die
wirklichen probleme adressiert das
öl-embargo funktioniert so nicht meine
damen und herren und an dieser stelle
ein herzliches dankeschön an ungarn die
sich also dagegen wehren und uns hier
noch ein wenig luft zum atmen
verschaffen
und g ungarn haben sie auch mal
beziffert was es sie kostet es kostet
sie 15 bis 18 milliarden euro und anhand
dieser zahlen können sie sich ja mal
ausrechnen was ist uns kostet wenn wir
dieses öl embargo wirklich durchführen
aber auch dazu haben wir keine
verlässliche politik diese kosten
beziffert ich hab's befragt ich habe die
bundesregierung gefragt und
normalerweise muss man diese kosten
berechnen wenn man denn einen solchen
tiefen einschnitt macht aber nichts da
und da auch erkennen wir eben diese
unverantwortliche politik hier zu lasten
unserer menschen im land und wir sehen
es ja eben auch gerade in der uckermark
pck schwedt da werden die lichter
ausgehen trotz aller schönen worte und
trotz aller beteuerung dass man das
verhindern möchte
aber die ersten mitarbeiter verlassen
dort schon das werk das heißt da ist
schon gezündelt worden und das heißt
dass dieses land jetzt dass dieses werk
jetzt schon anfängt auszubluten dank
dieser unverantwortlichen
politik der im wirtschaftlichen sinne
verbrannten erde meine damen und herren
arabic hat zwar ein alt geschworen dem
deutschen vom deutschen volk ein den
schaden abzuwenden aber er macht genau
das gegenteil er schädigt uns hier sehr
massiv und
und wenn wir dann die folgen betrachten
1200 arbeitnehmer in diesem werk und
nochmal zwei bis 4000 arbeitnehmer bei
den zulieferbetrieben dann ist das ein
kollateralschaden den wir so nicht
hinnehmen können das ist unsoziale
politik meine damen und herren und
herr beck hat uns auch an anderer stelle
getäuscht er hat eben gesagt die
laufzeitverlängerung der kraft der
kernkraftwerke würde nicht gas-reserven
einsparen aber das muss nichts ändern
denn wir haben viel viel mehr potenzial
da es einzusparen als er zugibt herunter
wir lehnen das ab
vielen dank
ja und das hat die ard in einem antrag
hier festgehalten zwei anträge der fw
diesen grundlage dieser debatte während
innerhalb der eu über ein ölembargo
gegen russland diskutiert wird lehnte
afd in deutschland das zumindest ab und
der zweite antrag auch das ist schon
angeklungen da geht es um die zukunft
der raffinerie in schwedt
dort wird ihr ausschließliche russisches
öl verarbeitet ich beginne mit einer
geschichte ich beginne mit meiner
geschichte und sie heißt am waldrand
am waldrand so ist die bushaltestelle
als ehrlich als sekt aus an der ich als
sechsjähriges mädchen immer einstieg um
in die musikschule zu fahren ich hatte
einen kleinen koffer roller und ein
akkordeon darauf wenn ich zurück kamen
stieg ich aus
diesem alten schlenker bus die drei
hohen stufen runter mit meinem koffer
roller und dem akkordeon darauf diese
bushaltestelle durfte ich nicht
verpassen
denn hätte ich sie verpasst wäre die
nächste haltestelle sehr weit weg
gewesen
straße f am pck entsteht oder
ich nahm also meine kleinen koffer
roller mit dem akkordeon drauf und zog
ihn über die frauen holprigen
betonplatten
vorbei an parkenden trabis wartburgs
rumpelt über die themen entlang unserer
wohnblocks dann trug ich mein akkordeon
in den vierten stock
in unserer wohnzimmerfenster vor dem
balkon leuchtete das ganze jahr ein
licht manchmal 2 die fackeln vom pck
das waren die 80er das war meine
kindheit neubau blöcke viele kinder die
sich morgens sammelten und gemeinsam zur
schule liefen draußen spielten im
ruderverein bahn in der musikschule wir
hatten ein theater ein centrum warenhaus
eine papierfabrik eine schuhfabrik
betonwerk und das pck in schwedt lebten
51.000 menschen
dann kam der mauerfall
die wiedervereinigung heute nennen dass
strukturwandel oder transformation
damals für mich für meine familie war es
einfach einen zusammenbruch ich war zehn
von den zeitweise über 8000
beschäftigten in der pck raffinerie
verloren über 7000 menschen ihre arbeit
und damit auch ihre perspektive die
papierfabrik endlich die mitarbeitenden
die schuhfabrik schloss das betonwerk
ebenso die arbeitslosenquote stieg auf
25 prozent so viele menschen verließen
diese region die bevölkerungszahl hatte
sich bis in die zweitausender mehr als
halbiert der wohnblock in dem ich
aufwuchs existiert heute nicht mehr auch
die kita die schulen die alte
musikschule das ganze wohnviertel kurz
gesagt die orte meiner kindheit die
wendejahre haben viele vor riesige
herausforderung gestellt aber die
menschen vor ort sind darin gewachsen
und haben ihr schwedt an der oder mit
ihrer erfahrung stärke zu dem gemacht
was es heute ist lebenswert eine eine
bedeutende stadt und 34 menschen sind
heute hier zu hause liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen gaben uns die aktuelle
weltpolitische lage nicht ausgesucht wir
können sie nicht ignorieren das
öl-embargo gegen russland ist der
versuch die maschinerie eines tricks
treibers nicht weiter anzuheizen
da schließen
das schließen der tür buch spar hat
natürlich folgen für die wirtschaft und
für die gesamte region ja für den ganzen
osten deutschland und wir tragen alle
gemeinsam die verantwortung die menschen
und unternehmen die von dieser
einschneidende maßnahme am härtesten
getroffen werden zu unterstützen und die
bundesregierung wird eine mit
kurzarbeiterregelung mit umfangreichen
wirtschaftshilfen und sie sorgt dafür
dass öl über andere wege ins land kommt
sie schreiben in ihrem antrag entsteht
wasserstoff zu produzieren ist kein
realitätsbezug das ist falsch wir wissen
alle dass die zukunft der pc karten
generiert nicht immer liegt die lösung
sind synthetische kraftstoffe
die umstellung ist lange geplant die
jetzige situation bietet die
herausforderung aber auch die chance
diese prozesse deutlich zu beschleunigen
allerdings kann selbstverständlich mal
mit der unterstützung des bundes
gelingen und es kann nur mit der
erfahrung stärke der menschen in dieser
region gelingen sie wissen die man aus
krisen kraft schöpft sie wissen jemand
eine transformation gestaltet denn sie
haben es schon einmal selbst getan
eines ins land die städte wirtschafts
und handelszentrum anschlüssen für sich
hat mir energie und mobilität so
entstand auch schritt an der oder mitten
in europa erneuerbare energien sind
unsere neuen flüsse dort siedeln sich
die unternehmen an dort wächst die
wirtschaft gute aktuelle beispiele sind
interne magdeburg oder tesla in
grünheide der antrag der alten menschen
vor dass alles so bleiben könnte die es
war krieg und ein mann der nicht
existiert das ist polemisch und höhnisch
und bietet keine antworten auf die
probleme dieser zeit sie verkauften den
verwundeten
wird es keine wirtschaftsstarkes
deutschland und europa geben ihr handeln
ist grob fahrlässig was lernen wir
daraus erneuerbare energien sind nicht
nur frei heizenergie sie sind auch
arbeitsplatz energie für das wachsen
einer neuen wirtschaft einem berg an
einem waldrand und im gesamten aufrufen
vielen dank
ja franziska schenk von der spd
die in der nähe der raffinerie pck in
schwedt
aufgewachsen ist dann bis zum teil der
die raffinerie schwedt vollständig von
der russischen öl ab die bundesregierung
sieht chance auch im falle eines öl
embargos der europäischen union gegen
russland die raffinerie zu erhalten bei
einem besuch in brandenburg hat
zumindest wirtschaftsminister habe
keinen plan gezeichnet wie der betrieb
in zukunft weiter laufen könnte
entgegen jede
woche in der in diesem krieg aus
deutschland geld an putin fließt ist
eine schlechte woche es ist eine
schlechte woche
es ist eine schlechte woche weil ein
embargo bei kohle dass wir haben und bei
öl das kommen muss die antwort ist auf
einen völkerrechtswidrigen krieg der von
putin ausgeht mit einem kriegsverbrecher
kann kein freundlicher handel
stattfinden es ist auch kein
freundlicher handel es wird seitens
russland schon jetzt energie es
wirtschaftlicher waffe gegen uns
eingesetzt beginnend mit der nicht
befüllung der gasspeicher und deshalb
ausdrücklich wir halten den weg
wegzukommen von russischen importen
unsere zahlungen zu stoppen für den
richtigen weg so schnell wie das möglich
ist deshalb beim gas mit schnellen
schritten so schnell wie möglich und bei
kohle und öl mit einem embargo es ist
der richtige weg ist findet unsere
unterstützung
die bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt nach
prüfung und vorbereitung dass ein öl
embargo für deutschland handhabbar ist
darauf stützen wir auch unsere erwartung
dass konkrete antworten gibt für schwere
das unternehmen für die mitarbeiter dort
dass es konkrete antworten gibt zur
sicherung der versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland insgesamt
in brandenburg und in berlin speziell
diese antworten sind in arbeit sie
müssen jetzt noch konkreter werden wir
verlassenes dorf und stützen uns auf
dass diese antworten kommen
und ich will dann
auch in diesem zusammenhang weil sie
ungern angesprochen haben sagen unsere
erwartung ist dass wenn dieses embargo
kommt das ist so konsequent wie möglich
umgesetzt wird dass es so wenig
ausnahmen wie möglich gibt es muss putin
treffen und wenn geld für öl wenn für
geld unterbrochen wird dann wird es ihn
treffen weil er mit öl mehr geld
verdient als mit kohle und mitgas es
trifft ihn und man muss es so abstützen
dass schiffe aus der eu kein öl aus
russland transportieren dass die nicht
versichert werden dass es keine
dienstleistung wird eine konsequente
umsetzung dieses erfahrungs dass unsere
erwartungen an die bundesregierung bei
den verhandlungen in brüssel
und wir drängen darauf beim öl beim gas
insgesamt bei russischer energie dass
jetzt die vorbereitungen getroffen
werden dass jetzt die vorbereitung
verstärkt werden dass wir ohne russische
energie über den nächsten winter kommen
es ist gut dass minister habe jetzt
angekündigt hat eine breit angelegte
energiesparkampagne wenn die ende mai
anfang juni kommt dann ist sie nicht zu
spät sie ist dringlich wir erwarten dass
es ein förderprogramm gibt ein
arbeitsprogramm für heizungsoptimierung
wenn massenhaft heizung optimiert werden
dann kann es dann wird es einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten da ist jetzt
die zeit dafür ist jetzt die zeit das
auf den weg zu bringen es vorzubereiten
es gibt
es gibt in italien seit dem ersten mai
eine regelung dass in öffentlichen
einrichtungen
mit den klimaanlagen die temperatur nur
auf 27 grad runtergekühlt werden kann
und nicht weiter wir erwarten dass es
für öffentliche einrichtungen seitens
der bundesregierung vorschläge gibt was
ist hier an einsparungen möglich und
vertretbar wir erwarten dass insgesamt
einen plan gibt wie wir uns jetzt
vorbereiten wie wir strom der in
gaskraftwerken erzeugt wird kompensieren
können wir einsparungen umsetzen können
wie wir im gesamten kontext uns jetzt
darauf vorbereiten dass wir auch ohne
russische energie gut durch zum nächsten
winter kommen können ist er zwei seiten
des eine es geht darum die zahlungen so
schnell wie möglich zu stoppen und das
andere es geht darum uns unabhängig zu
machen beides ist richtig wenn hier
vorschläge vorgelegt werden unterstützen
wir die wir drängen darauf dass die
gemacht werden und in diesem sinne
werden wir diese debatte führen in
diesem sinne er war meine vorschläge in
deutschland und in diesem sinne
unterstützen eintreten der
bundesregierung in brüssel herzlichen
dank
die bundesregierung hält ein öl embargo
für deutschland mittlerweile für
verkraftbar auf eu ebene wird munter
diskutiert und gerade heute hat ja die
eu kommission einen plan vorgelegt
mit dem sich die versuchen will von
russischer energie zu lösen wie das
gehen könnte es gibt hier die eu
kommission in einem umfassenden paket
300 milliarden euro für mehr
unabhängigkeit von russischer energie
sollen das sollen dazu eingesetzt werden
in der ukraine und das wäre dann ein
grund sozusagen für die russische
invasion und so passt auch der heutige
antrag wieder in ihre verschwörungs
erzählung dass sie nicht begreifen warum
wir diese maßnahmen nämlich tätigen ich
erkläre ihnen nochmal russland hat einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg in
der ukraine eingeleitet und wie als
europäische union haben uns entschieden
unsere volkswirtschaften vollständig
abzukoppeln von der russischen
volkswirtschaft und warum haben wir das
getan weil wir nicht möchten dass
russland erneut in der lage sein wird
auf unsere kosten seiner eigenen armeen
auszurüsten und andere länder
anzugreifen und das ist der grund warum
wir das tun wollte
und trotzdem
das ist richtig
auch offen zu sagen dass das auch kosten
für uns bedeutet robert habeck war in
schwedt robert habeck ist in leuna
gewesen und hat den menschen dort auch
zusagen gemacht dass wir helfen werden
dass wir auch entsprechend in dem wir
jetzt mit polen zum beispiel
übereinkommen schließen sicherstellen
dass die raffinerien in schwedt eine
zukunft hat und dass man in der zukunft
dann darüber hinaus auch über das thema
wasserstoff erneuerbare energien tun wir
jetzt schon sehr viel wenn sie heute
durch den osten fahren die windräder
würden wir gern in bayern haben die wir
im osten haben uns fehlt die energie
dort ist jetzt da sie haben es die ganze
zeit gekämpft und ruinieren damit der
restlichen ihre eigenen regionen auch
mit ihrer fremdenfeindlichkeit diese
immer vor sich hat
der entscheidende punkt aber ist was sie
auch nicht verstehen ist dass das alles
vergangenheit ist was sie beschwören was
möchten sie den erreichen eine weitere
abhängigkeit vom russischen erdgas öl
und kohle wollen sie das zur abstimmung
stellen in deutschland im deutschen
bundestag freising in ihrer wählerschaft
oder wollen sie vielleicht mal in die
zukunft blicken nämlich das zeitalter
von energieeinsparung erneuerbaren
energien grünem wasserstoff gigantischen
investitionen die wir auf den weg
bringen das hat doch nicht nur begonnen
dass es voll in schwung und die
europäische union hat sich committed
andreas jungen wie alle gemeinsam zu
sagen wir wollen diesen weg gehen und
sie sind ganz allein und wir sind ganz
kleine mit dieser haltung zu sagen sie
wollen den russischen weg gegen die
russische volkswirtschaft ist eine der
schlechteste verifizierten
volkswirtschaften die wir überhaupt in
europa im eurasischen bereich haben wir
haben nichts mehr außer öl kohle und gas
sie haben keine modernisierung
vorgenommen keine digitalisierung sie
haben auch nicht es geschafft sich in
irgendeiner weise auf die zukunft
einzustellen und die zukunft das ist das
was die bundesregierung mit weiten
teilen der und positionen der
unterstützung auch voranbringen
erneuerbare energien einsparungen nach
vorne geht investieren den wohlstand
halten mit diesen bedingungen und mit
dem nicht zurückschauen und sagen wir
wollen mit den zahlen der vergangenheit
die zukunft schaffen das wird nicht
funktionieren wir müssen das so machen
wie wir es gemacht haben und
vorantreiben ich danke ihnen hast du
vielleicht denken sie mal ein bisschen
[Applaus]
der kollege alexander ullrich spricht
für die fraktion die linke
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
der russische angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine ist durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen und deshalb ist es auch
notwendig über sanktionen nachzudenken
wir erinnern aber die bundesregierung
ihr versprechen auch an die deutsche
bevölkerung
dass sie sanktionen uns nicht härter
treffen dürfen wie putin russland beim
öl embargo ist das aber leider der fall
wir haben letzte woche schauen als linke
eine aktuelle stunde im bundestag
eingebracht und haben darauf hingewiesen
was das bedeutet für die für
ostdeutschland für berlin was öl angeht
aber auch für die region um spät mit
tausenden von arbeitsplätzen und wir
haben auch darauf aufmerksam gemacht
dass ein teil mittwoch gab es viele
diskussionen und inflation und höhere
preise dass wir auch dazu beitragen
diesen ölembargo dass preise und
inflation weiter steigen und der
lachende gewinner dabei ist leider denen
sie damit schaden wollen denn russland
hat dadurch geringeren einnahmen zum
einen weil wir ja dass erst bis ende des
jahres umsetzen wollen in dieser zeit
steigen sogar die preise putin verdient
an dieser debatte und erwischte auch in
dieses jahres soweit sein auch dieses öl
irgendwo anders in der welt zu verkaufen
das heißt wir schaden mit einem
ölembargo
hier und selbst und tausende
arbeitsplätze deshalb leben wir als
linke das ab
nachher die art erst diese woche uns
nach rennt bei dieser debatte ein und
es ist das eine oder andere falsch wenn
es uns abschreiben aber noch einmal jung
ich kann es nicht verstehen dass sie
hier sagen jeden tag jeden tag wo wir
sozusagen das bezahlen bezahlen wir
putin und seinen krieg aber dieser
konsequenz müssen sie dann auch sagen
sofort raus auch aus den ausbau aus dem
gas und damit würden sie das wissen sie
es selbst der deutsche industrie sagt
ihnen das doch jeden tag wer aufs gas
und öl aus streit gefährdet
hunderttausende arbeitsplätze es ist gut
dass hier nur mit klar geworden ist die
cdu/csu-fraktion spielt mitunter
tausenden arbeitsplätzen in diesem land
wir haben deshalb letzte woche ihnen
gesagt wir brauchen ausnahmeregelungen
für ostdeutschland wiederholen diese
forderung weil ansonsten geht hier
wirklich ende des jahres bei vielen
sprichwörtlich das licht aus und die
preise werden immer wieder weiter
steigen an den tankstellen es gibt
experten die sagen da könnte sogar
preise von drei euro aufgerufen werden
für diesel und benzin das sage ich schon
das ist etwas was die grünen auch mal
lernen müssen auch beim thema
energiewende müssen auch die sozial
benachteiligen diesem land das mitgehen
können die menschen in diesem land
werden den klima die klimapolitik und
den umstieg auf neue energien dann
mitmachen wenn auch sie das bezahlen
können und darauf geben sie keine
antworten und habig sagt sogar noch dann
wird der wohlstand verlieren die
menschen die irgendwo in schwedt oder
woanders wo nur jeden tag mit dem auto
vom flachen land in die stadt zum
arbeitsvertrag und antworten aber nicht
solche wohlfeile reden von menschen über
20.000 euro im monat verdienen
[Applaus]
zum satzende und ergänzt dieser bohrer
unsere debatte wir müssen endlich auch
die ölkonzerne heranziehen über gewinn
steuer schauen sie sich an was dieser
zeit einen reibach machen das buch
schwerlich abgeschöpfte an vielen dank
sagt alexander ulrich für die linke erst
der sprecher für industriepolitik der
linksfraktion wenn wir als nächsten in
dieser aussprache zu den beiden anträgen
der afg fraktion michael kruse von der
fdp gehört frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
auf den tribünen hier im raum sitzen in
dieser minute sehr viele junge menschen
diese jungen menschen die da oben sitzen
sitzen da
vermutlich zum allerersten mal
diese jungen menschen bekommen einen
eindruck davon wie das parlament
miteinander diskutiert
ich bin überzeugt dass jeder einzelne
und jede einzelne die jetzt gerade hier
oben auf der tribüne sitzt in der lage
wäre die peinliche argumentation die wir
hier von den beiden außenseiten von
links und rechts gehört haben im keim zu
verlegen weil das was sie hier tun
das was sie hier tun ist dermassen
atemberaubend
dass man es auch nicht unwidersprochen
stehen lassen kann ich habe mir kurz
überlegt ich habe mir kurz überlegt wenn
der wladimir putin hier im haus jetzt
eine debatte anmelden dürfte wie wäre
der titel dieser debatte und ich habe
mir überlegt er könnte ungefähr so
lauten kein öl embargo schutz für bürger
und unternehmen
denn was dieser titel tut ist ja eher
versucht auf eine ganz perfide art und
weise
zusammenhang herzustellen zwischen einem
schutz für all die menschen dem wir hier
im raum als volksvertreterin und
volksvertreter verpflichtet sind in dem
sie so tun als wenn wenn wir uns von
russland unabhängig machen wir die
menschen nicht mehr schützen genau das
gegenteil ist der fall und deswegen ist
schon ihre titel anmeldung hohn und
spott für dieses hohe haus meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren aber
können auch einfach mal in ihr
wahlprogramm schauen haben sie auch
nicht getan es ist grundsätzlich
eigentlich auch ein fehler ich zitiere
mal aus ihrem wahlprogramm
scheint ja seite richtig auch protest zu
stoßen bei ihnen wenn man aus ihrem
wahlprogramm zitieren möchte was also
ich lese daraus vor
wir lehnen es ab dass sich die
bundesregierung zunehmend als
unternehmer versteht und betätigt das
aber genau das was sie hier jetzt
eingefordert haben es genau das was sie
hier eingefordert haben also sie müssen
sich dann ja auch schon mal entscheiden
ob sie jetzt dem weg gehen wollen den
sie uns sonst immer vorschlagen sie
beschweren sich dass ich das jetzt hier
vorträge haben sie haben es ja auch
geschrieben oder ob sie den wir gehen
wollen den sie in der aktuellen stunde
vorschlagen wir können für die regierung
tragenden fraktionen sagen und ich freue
mich dass sich auch die union in dieser
haltung angeschlossen hat in europa
wurde ein angriffskrieg begonnen und
zwar von russland sie und gerade sie
auch herr kurth rät der sie hier heute
gesprochen haben sie sind regelmäßig
nicht mal in der lage an diesem pulk
hier festzustellen dass russland diesen
krieg begonnen hat sie sind regelmäßig
56 minuten an diesem rednerpult ohne
einmal zu erwähnen wer hier gerade
menschen in europa abschlachtet und von
ihnen jetzt einen solchen antrag zu
bekommen dass der gipfel der
parlamentarischen frechheit in dieser
legislaturperiode meine damen und herren
und dass ihnen in ihrer politischen
verwirrung dass ihnen in ihrer
politischen verwirrung die linke auch
noch folgt das finde ich wirklich
bemerkenswert und dann sagen sie ja wir
müssen hier in unserer konsequenz auch
aus gas aussteigen er was
aber haben sie mal auf die tagesordnung
morgen geschaut da ist das lg
beschleunigungsgesetz drauf das haben
wir in der letzten woche eingebracht das
werden wir in dieser woche beschließen
das wird übermorgen im bundesrat
behandelt das wird zum ersten juni dann
in kraft treten wissen was das das
schnellste gesetz was in dieser
legislatur wahrscheinlich in den ganzen
letzten jahren durch dieses haus
gelaufen ist und was tun wir damit wir
machen uns unabhängiger von russischem
gas weil wir dafür sorgen dass in
deutschland und auch in europa lng
import infrastruktur geschaffen wird
diese infrastruktur wird benötigt damit
wir uns unabhängig machen von russischem
gas ob beim öl weil der kohle oder beim
gas wir sorgen dafür dass lange putin
der geldhahn aus deutschland abgedreht
wird und in ihrer und in ihrer
interessenslage ist genau das gegenteil
verhaftet dann machen sie sich aber auch
mit verantwortlich für all das was dort
passiert herzlichen dank meine damen
michael kruse war das für die
fdp-fraktion und ein kleiner vorausblick
auf morgen in einem gut gefüllten
sitzungstag und tatsächlich unter
anderem ein tagesordnungspunkt
morgen da geht es um den beschleunigten
bau von flüssiggasterminals
meinte kaufmann jetzt für die fdp
herr kruse sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren der große hätten
sie heute die nachrichten meldungen
gelesen eine ente festgestellt dass
dieses thema kein öl embargo eben gerade
heute nicht von russland kamen sondern
von den vereinigten staaten von amerika
die das nicht haben wollen und druck auf
europa ausüben so ist die wahrheit so
viel zu ihren verschwörungstheorien die
sie hier verbreiten
seit 24 jahren sitzt die spd nahezu
ununterbrochen in der bundesregierung
hat kräftig daran mitgewirkt unser land
in eine völlig unverantwortliche und
energiepolitische abhängigkeit zu
bringen die folge wir können heute auf
russisches öl und gas eben nicht
verzichten ohne dass es zu massiven
problemen in unserem land kommen wird
was sind die wirkungen und
nebenwirkungen eines embargos die eine
reaktion ist völlig klar mein kollege
hat es ausgeführt russland verkauft sein
öl dann eben an china und indien
pakistan andere länder vielleicht sogar
zu einem verbilligten preis das wird
unsere eigenen wirtschaft zusätzlich
schaden die leitet nämlich heute schon
unter ihren gewollt absurd hohen
energiepreisen meine damen und herren
was ist wenn uns russland als
gegenmaßnahme dem geld den gashahn
zudreht wenn die gaskraftwerke nicht
anlaufen können zur stabilisierung ihres
rot-grünen flattr stroms und die
unternehmen aufhören müssen zu
produzieren und ein weiteres problem
wird von der regierung einfach vom tisch
gewischt zuletzt im ausschuss frau
staatssekretärin brand auf meine
nachfrage
die take or pay klauseln in den
gaslieferverträgen bergen potenziell ein
multimilliarden risiko für deutsche
strafzahlungen der hinweis auf höhere
gewalt im falle eines gas in bagus zur
vermeidung solcher strafen ist dünnes
eis und sollte dieses nicht halten wird
es für uns alle richtig teuer fazit dank
der langjährigen energiepolitik von
schröder märkte und jetzt auch stolz
wäre derzeit einen öl oder gas embargo
gegen russland
unverantwortlich für unser eigenes land
deshalb finger weg von derartigen plänen
vielen dazwischen dank
der kollege timon
der kollege timon gremmels spricht jetzt
führt hier ist die produktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herrn doktor
kaufmann r die spd hat die letzten 24
jahre mitregiert ist auch gut so was
haben wir die letzten 24 jahre gemacht
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass der anteil
erneuerbarer energien in deutschland bei
fast 50 prozent ist das ist unser
verdienst und diana waren energie im
bereich der erneuerbaren energien dass
wir die so ausgebaut haben insbesondere
auch im bereich des stroms sorgen dafür
dass die abhängigkeit von fossilen
importen heute deutlich geringer ist
meine sehr verehrten mutter das ist doch
die wahrheit das ist doch die wahl und
ich sage ihnen klar das thema embargo
ist ein sehr kritisches und da gibt es
auch keine leichten antworten und
deswegen ist es doch gut dass diese
bundesregierung auch ohne öl embargo
schon gehandelt hat seit dezember
letzten jahres haben wir unseren anteil
an russischem öl von 35 auf 12 prozent
gesenkt das haben wir ganz ohne ende
geschafft meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und das ist auch der richtige weg
das genauso zu machen und das ist aus
meiner sicht in der tat richtig wir
haben fast überall und unabhängig machen
können und die achillesferse ist schwer
das ist pck schwedt das wissen wir alle
wegen einer besonderheit dort ist es so
dass die firma rosneft 90 prozent anteil
hat und wir an der ölpipeline druschba
hängen und es nicht einfach um steller
ist wie das in anderen
raffinerien in deutschland der fall ist
das gehört auch zur wahrheit dazu und
deswegen wird es doch besonders schwerer
in dieser letzten zwölf prozent zu
kompensieren und umzustellen das ist
eine herausforderung und deswegen sagen
wir ja das was sie um kommission jetzt
klagt nicht von heute auf morgen ein
embargo sondern weg aufzuzeigen
innerhalb der nächsten sechs monate das
hinzubekommen ist der richtige weg weil
diese sechs monate werden wir auch in
deutschland noch brauchen um den hafen
in rostock die pipeline auf den weg zu
bringen zu ertüchtigen ist es gerade
angesprochen worden in danzig gibt es
gespräche auch mit der polnischen
regierung auch dort zu gucken wie dort
schiffe an landen können wie das öl
deutschland über die druschba pipeline
über danzig richtung spät kommt kann
genau das macht diese bundesregierung
das ist auch der richtige weg meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und da denke
ich insbesondere auch robert habeck und
kanzler olaf scholz der am wochenende ja
auch den beschäftigten ein klares signal
gegeben hat wir werden das nicht auf
ihren rücken ausfechten sondern wir
stehen solidarisch an der seite der 1200
beschäftigten in spe sehr verehrten
damen und natürlich
ist eine sanktion ein scharfes schwert
zwei drittel der verkäufe finanzieren
den russischen staatshaushalt bei gas
sind es nur 7 prozent das heißt das für
putin am ende des tages spüren aber in
der tat müssen wir aufpassen dass wir
weltwirtschaftlich hier nicht die
energie kosten nach oben steigen und
natürlich müssen wir auch aufpassen dass
das öl was nicht mehr nach europa und
deutschland verkauft wird dann nach
indien wo anders hin geht es ja nicht
weg also die herausforderung die wir
haben sind doch groß und sind sind nicht
klein zu reden aber deswegen müssen wir
uns dort genau diesen weg jetzt in
solidarität in europa miteinander
bestreiten und deswegen auch mein appell
richtung ungarn richtung slowakei
das gemeinschaftlich jetzt auf den weg
zu bringen und wir uns nicht spalten zu
lassen weil dann lacht sich doch putin
sie voll ins fünfte meine damen und
herren deswegen müssen wir das
gemeinschaftlich machen und ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir den nächsten
tagen auf europäischer ebene da einen
guten kompromiss hinkriegen der auch die
energiepolitische verantwortung auch die
verantwortung für die energiepreise in
europa und in deutschland mit
berücksichtigt meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und ich sage ihnen
das was jetzt in schwedt passiert
wäre auch oben wann passiert ganz ohne
frage embargo nämlich die umstellung
weil wir haben uns doch verständigt in
dieser koalition bis 20.45 klimaneutral
zu sein das heißt irgendwann wäre auch
dort eine umstellung eine transformation
nötig gewesen die ziehen wir jetzt vor
und die muss auch finanziert
ausgestattet werden und da gibt es
zusagen von herrn habeck da hat sich
olaf scholz am wochenende auch klar zu
committed wir werden die menschen
deutlich allein dass wir werden den
umbau die transformation zu maßnahmen in
schwedt mit den menschen
gemeinschaftlich voranbringen und es ist
aber nirgends dafür dass wir jetzt die
erzeugung dort umstellen hinzu
basischemikalien dass sie die erzeugung
um stellen hin zu synthetischen
kraftstoffen auf der basis von grünen
wasserstoff das ist doch die zukunft wir
sorgen dafür dass die arbeitsplätze in
schmidt zukunft sehe ich sind meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und nicht
rückwärtsgewandt sind wir machen das
moderne und ich wir werden das jetzt
einfach nur ein stück weit beschleunigen
die transformation auch sie finanziell
abfedern unterstützen und ist liegt eine
große chance drin weil wir können
schwedt und die dortige raffinerie hin
zu einer zukunftsstrategie machen das
ist die aufgabe die diese
bundesregierung wahrnimmt das ist eine
große herausforderung das ist nicht
einfach aber wir können das schaffen mit
den beschäftigten mit den arbeitnehmern
und arbeitnehmerinnen und ihren familien
in schwedt und in der ganzen region
brandenburg und in ganz aus deutschland
das ist unsere aufgabe das dann
herausforderung aber wir gehen diesen
beschwerlichen und hält schweren bewegt
weil wir der auffassung sind da nun
liegt eine zukunft die erneuerbaren
energien das sind die zukunft und dafür
brauchen wir gut qualifizierte
beschäftigte auch aus dieser region in
diesem sinne blick auf meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren er sagt timon
gremmels für die sozialdemokraten und es
gibt auch hinweise wie es mit schritt
weiter gehen könnte mit der raffinerie
der ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung
kassen schneider rechnet so hörte man
zumindest gestern damit dass in kurzer
zeit mit einer neuen
gesellschafterstruktur bei der
raffinerie zu rechnen sei die ja bisher
mehrheitlich dem russischen
staatskonzern rosneft gehört
ungerührt und es gibt auch niemanden der
ein schnelles ende will muss die frage
ist welche schritte dazu gibt es und ein
ölembargo ist es im zweifel nicht das
ist jedenfalls meine meinung und egal
wie gut es gemeint ist wir können uns
nicht schwächen wenn wir anderen helfen
wollen wir müssen vom ende her denken
die forderung nach einem ölembargo hat
zu viel verunsicherung geführt
existenzängste geschürt und sowohl die
unkenntnis über die fakten bei der
bundesregierung als auch die verdrängung
der ernsten lage bei der
versorgungssicherheit haben das noch
verstärkt hier ist eher der wunsch vater
des gedanken das motto es wird schon
irgendwie gut gehen ist wie ein
auf der rasierklinge dazu wenige punkte
in ein paar wenigen punkt ein paar
anmerkungen punkt eins es ist kein
regionales problem irgendwo in den
fernen weiten endlosen weiten der
uckermark und auch kein rein
ostdeutsches problem und ich sage das
als später der eben gerade in diesen pck
auch seine ausbildung zum
elektrotechniker gemacht hat
ostdeutschland wird zwar die größte last
tragen ohne zweifel aber die folgen
werden sich auf die gesamte
bundesrepublik deutschland auswirken
punkt zwei
die gefährliche ignoranz der fakten in
der bundesregierung der besuch von
minister habe ich in der schwedter
raffinerie hat die ganze planlosigkeit
der bundesregierung offenbart es wurde
dort geredet von arbeitsplätzen es wurde
dort geredet von bundeshilfen für spät
es wurde geredet über die goldene
zukunft des wasserstoffs in 20 jahren es
wurde davon geredet einen plan zu haben
soder davon geredet gute gespräche zu
führen aber die versorgungssicherheit
von rostock ist nach suhl das wurde
außen vor gelassen
und dabei liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist die erdölpipeline freundschaft nach
schwedt der dreh und angelpunkt für die
versorgungssicherheit in einem großen
teil der bundesrepublik wie sollen denn
zwölf millionen tonnen jahresproduktion
in schwedt ersetzt werden die frage
bleibt unbeantwortet
und es ist zu befürchten dass es
erhebliche versorgungsengpässe im
gesamten osten in vielen bereichen des
öffentlichen lebens geben wird wo meine
damen und herren können denn
westdeutsche raffinerien bei der
kapazität aushelfen bei der fehlenden
infrastruktur wie viele tkb es müssten
dann jeden tag dann fahren von westen
nach osten 3000 4000 die frage bleibt
unbeantwortet
wie können
70.000 tonnen pro tag über die erste
leitung freundschaft ersetzt werden
keine antwort wie können
12.000 32.000 tonnen pro tag die alleine
die raffinerie schwedt braucht um
einigermaßen effizient zu fahren er
selbst wer keine antwort über die
leitung rostock was immer gesagt wird
wird die leitung rostock kommen
lediglich
19.000 tonnen pro tag und das wo kommt
der rest her so staatssekretärin keine
antwort was denn wirklich über den hafen
rostock an landen kann was wirklich mal
den hafen rostock anlagen kann der er
noch viel zu flach dass der partie der
die die wassertiefe nicht ausreicht
keine antwort da komme ich zum punkt 3
die weltfremde arglosigkeit
der bundesregierung die diversifizierung
der rohstoffimporte ist eine wichtige
aufgabe sie überhaupt gar keine frage
aber absolut unverständlich ist wie das
ölembargo von deutschland aus ohne eine
lösung so massiv vorangetrieben werden
kann und die bundesregierung suggeriert
sogar dass die versorgung über schwedt
mit zwei schiffen in der woche irgendwo
über rostock funktionieren kann der rest
würde dann irgendwo aus tanz dich kommen
das bringt mich zum dritten punkt offene
fragen oft gestellt im ausschuss und
überall nicht beantwortet welche zwei
schiffe sind das welche kapazität haben
diese schiffe können die schiffe den
hafen rostock angefahren werden weil er
zu flaches muss derart vertieft werden
wie lange dauert die ausbaggerung ist
die vorbereitung schon gemacht gibt es
genehmigungen ist die richtige mischung
für die raffinerie schwedt überhaupt
verfügbar welche umrüstungen müssen
gemacht werden und so weiter und so fort
hier gibt es viele fragen die ich noch
anmerken könnte ölreserve welche
verträge mit 20 alternative ölimporte
oder ist es am ende das gleiche
russische öl das wir war eine andere
flacke dann über die leitung bekommen
wie sieht die logistik aus und so weiter
und so fort
damen und herren es mag sein dass das
renitente fragen sind aber bevor man ein
ölembargo macht muss man fragen
beantworten die bleiben unbenannt an
oder sind im nebel der worthülsen nicht
mehr zu erkennen
und das prinzip hoffnung ist mir aus
sicht der lage und ernsthaftigkeit zu
wenig und ich schließe mich daher der
bundesregierung der brandenburgischen
landesregierung an die gesagt hat jede
woche ohne ein embargo ist eine gute
woche vielen dank
die jens koeppen für die cdu csu
fraktion war dass der selbst gesagt hat
er hat in schwedt mal seine lehre
gemacht er hat auch seinen wahlkreis in
brandenburg und hat hier seine position
deutlich gemacht letzte rednerin jetzt
ingrid nestle für die grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen den anträgen der afg können wir
natürlich nicht zustimmen auch wenn sie
wieder so ein bisschen wolf im
schafspelz daher kommen deswegen lohnt
sich einmal die begründung zu schauen
was schreiben sie nämlich die
bundesregierung habe klarzustellen dass
die bringschuld nur zu sagen sie
gegenüber dem deutschen volk gilt und
bringen das in zusammenhang damit dass
durch ein öl-embargo öl deutlich teurer
werden könnte ich sage
ich bringe es mal zusammen was das
bedeutet ja sie sagen egal jain ist es
egal dass die städte zerbombt werden in
der ukraine
ihnen ist es egal dass frauen
vergewaltigt werden sie sagen was
kümmert es uns ja wenn dort hunger und
not herrschen hauptsache die preise
gehen nicht nach oben sie haben es
genauso in der begründung
zusammengebracht und deswegen die reine
freude sein gleich zu diesen anderen mit
nein zu stimmen
ich bin auch ich bin auch sehr stolz
dass die mehrheit in unserem land ganz
andere sind und dass die menschen in
diesem land solidarisch sind mit der
ukraine und da sie nicht sagen
hauptsache der ölpreis stimmt was auch
immer dort passiert und dass sie sagen
es ist unsere verantwortung unseren
beitrag dazu zu leisten dass dieser
krieg dass dieser angriffskrieg in der
ukraine endet
die mehrheit der menschen möchte so die
daten ukraine seien arbeitsplätze gehen
gerade nicht dadurch verloren dass wir
uns um schwedt kümmern die zukunft von
schwedt die liegt auch nicht bei rosneft
putin hat doch gerade erst bewiesen
durch seine aktion bei gazprom germania
wie schnell er bereit ist unternehmen in
deutschland aufzugeben und aktiv kaputt
zu machen das waren mich sein plan 100
davon abgehalten hätte die zukunft der
arbeiter entsteht sie liegt noch nicht
bei uns nie die zukunft gearbeitet und
schwedt dafür kämpft oder tabak seit
wochen das ist die chance die sie haben
und tatsächlich ist lob auch angebracht
dafür dass diese bundesregierung kurs
gehalten hat mit ruhiger hand sowohl in
den zeiten als es zu klagen als wahr
sein uhr deutschland gegen das öl
embargo und alle zehn finger auf uns
zeigen genauso wie jetzt wo mit
sorgfältiger vorbereitung die
bundesregierung geklärt hat dass wir mit
einem ölembargo zurecht kommen nicht
ohne irgendwelche möglichkeiten und
jahren am berliner flughafen dann mal
nicht ganz so viel kerosin da ist das
mag sein aber dass wir damit
zurechtkommen und genauso jetzt mit
ruhiger hand diese linie weiterfahren wo
plötzlich die position dagegen kommen
sagen öl embargo auf keinen fall und ich
will nur daran erinnern die situation
ist genauso neu die korona pandemie für
uns war und deswegen ist es
bemerkenswert mit welcher klarheit die
regierung führung bewiesen hat in dieser
zeit
und da hilft es auch nicht erkennen dass
sie behaupten wir würden die augen
schließen vor der versorgungssicherheit
sie außer acht verlassen seit wochen und
lange bevor sie von der linken letzte
woche die aktuelle stunde eingebracht
haben zu den arbeitsplätzen in schwedt
hat minister radweg sich
auseinandergesetzt mit ölen mischungen
die man braucht mit tankkapazität mit
pipeline durchmessern ja und genau das
uns vorgerechnet und wenn sie es nicht
hören wollen er hat es uns trotzdem
vorgerechnet
fotolia und ingrid nestle hier mit ihrem
letzten redebeitrag
das thema öl embargo so viel darf ich
ihnen auch sagen das wird ein auge auf
den bundestag beschäftigen denn
bundeskanzler urlaubs der gibt am
donnerstag eine regierungserklärung zum
ausserordentlichen eu gipfel am 30
sondern 1 und 2 in brüssel bei dem
treffen der staats und regierungschefs
dürfte es auch vor allem um den ukraine
krieg und seine folgen gehen
beispielsweise ein mögliches öl-embargo
gegen russland also morgen 8 uhr 45
wieder hier live aus dem deutschen
bundestag ich verabschiede mich für
heute von ihnen aber bleiben sie weiter
bei phoenix